this is a very typical question it's a
very tool question so far we've just
looked at circular motion and either
there's been no surface that this thing
has been spinning on so it's just sort
of spinning freely out in the air or
it's been a flat surface okay those are
the simplest kind but then we all we
have all kinds of variations of
different things that you might be
spinning around rotating around okay and
this is one of the examples now in the
text all you're being asked to use can
you resolve the forces can use off the
forces and you can see everything is all
in terms of abstract stuff none of these
angles have been given to you none of
the masses of goods give me the masses
have been given to you all that kind of
thing is left off so after you resolve
the forces you then we'll punch on all
these numbers and they'll ask you
something like find out what the angular
velocities or find out what speed is the
maximum for it to etc stay on the
surface of the coloring or something
like that okay but that's kind of all of
that is mostly numerical work okay so I
think the key thing in mechanics is
being able to see through this diagram
resolve the forces first and then
everything if you've done it accurately
sort of just fits into place so to
resolve forces I want us to have a look
at this you can see I'm going to think
about this in two ways right you can see
there's going to be forces that result
from the tension of this stream or just
one thing missing here is tension that's
holding it sort of upwards okay and then
secondly there's the surface that you're
on and that's interacting with you and
what you can see is this normal this
reaction force okay that's sort of
responding there so what I want to do is
that over here that's pulling off in a
direction toward the center button
commit so I'm going to resolve the
forces for that and then you've got the
normal force you're going to resolve the
forces for that once you've got each of
those who put together for what's
happening vertically and was horribly
horizontally and there are all your
equations okay so the first thing you
want to my dad is resolving forces
because that's what we're actually going
to do
okay the first one is the tension in the
street subject that tension and then a
long link we've seen this before along
with this main diagram this primary
diagram I'm going to draw to sort of
subsidiary diagrams one of which
represents attention and one which
represents the normal I think you're
crazy if you want to try and put even
like this day man it's as busy as I want
any diagram to bed so even though you
could try it like in theory it's all bad
right I think this has just become too
crazy and you're you're misseldon point
details okay also the lovely thing about
doing this is that each time you do this
is just like what you did with
projectile motion which you're really
good at so it's boring a skill you had
from before and just applying it here
with one key difference that i'll show
you the moon ok so first let's draw the
direction direction that the tension is
going in ok its scale doesn't really
matter ok like which which angles facing
it's just the direction that's the
important thing it's heading toward the
center and upwards ok then what you've
got along with this and to you some
colors here what you got along with this
is there a vertical component like this
and then there's a horizontal component
like that ok now um I got asked the
question before I think it's actually
Doris you asked me so I'll have to tell
her when we women nexia why don't we
like put a box around this why not just
the triangle ok I like the box here's
why because if I draw a boss I guess
I'll repeat this later on then it helps
me take advantage now this is a
rectangle right the actual length I want
are these two but if i can find either
of these that's equivalent right but
finding these these are not the forces
these are the forces like we know where
this thing is coming from this p where
this thing is coming from and therefore
where e is facing is critically
important it makes all the difference in
vectors and therefore in these forces
and resolving them and combining them
properly ok
so I've got these guys because one is
the horizontal component i'm going to
call it oops x24 tension and because i
got the other one which is a very
important component in a call it why
team for attention right now the last
important thing to put onto here is the
angle right and noting where the eagle
is is very important so you can see it's
the angle between the string and the
vertical right so it's this semi vertex
angle up there so I'm going to put it in
there which means i can also put it in
here because of alternate angles okay
wonderful so now I've got everything set
up to resolve my forces I just need to
use right angled right angled triangle
tree to find out what these two things
are ok so let's start with the
horizontal force if I've got theater
over here how am I going to relate the
horizontal forsooth attention it's just
going to be sorry right so sine theta
equals opposite on hypotenuse so I don't
need to write anything else from that
bullet into his rearrange so I'm going
to put that proper result on to the
diagram XT is just going to be a side
view yeah you happy with that you could
almost see by analogy what the vertical
component is going to be but I still
like to write it because these will be
arranged differently sometimes I'll find
the I'm really interested in the
vertical one whatever so I'll say cos
theta because it's jason i don't i
produce is the vertical component / the
tension ok so on the basis of this i'm
going to say this is t what's they done
now just before I move on to the normal
force I'm sort of point out i think the
keto you ever one who mentioned actually
this looks a bit this is funny is like
it's the opposite of what we are used to
and that's because well in projectile
motion and in on the unit circle we're
so used to co-sign ving the x-coordinate
and time being the y coordinate okay can
any other tell me why is that they are
swapped around in this case
yeah yeah it's exactly about the
position in unicorn let me just remind
you for example on the unit circle when
you have your circle around like that
where is it that I measured the angle
from to get say cos theta sine theta up
here where is it made from its measured
from the horizontal right so there we go
so there's feet up right and measures
from the horizontal goodbye up this way
okay because you're measuring from the
vertical essentially what you're
measuring is the compliment right let
you see that that's the convert a bit
compliment compliment okay so as a
result because you're measuring the
compliment cause of pylon 2 minus theta
is sine theta okay so that's why
everything is switched around